foreign
[Music]
hey you guys what's going on it's Friday
[__] finally and I mean I thought I
was in the uh in the video next no
you're not okay you're well into this
video
I'm in the Right video yeah I guess so
Jenny let's go well she's sick yeah well
you know she's mad at me
she's mad at me because I wanted to go
out he wants to go to mannequins again
yeah why I don't I don't know I don't
understand it so I guess I guess we're
going but see here's the deal if we go
there and [__] I'm gonna have a
horrible time probably now we'll just
come back early well you wanted to go so
we're going
that's how it works you made me rush and
like put new makeup on and [__] I'm in
the mood to go okay if you're not in the
mood to go I mean you can stay here I
can go but she's like ah I let him down
there by himself that's what that's what
you know well no I mean if you're going
out then I guess I'll go out too it's
like you know you're gonna complain the
whole time how do you know
and you'll forget about
about it get a few drinks and you'll
probably have a good time but well I
don't know it depends on who's there
doesn't it yeah I thought I was gonna
have a good time last time but look how
that works she is the thing man women
don't deal well with trauma you know
trauma changes them negatively
[__] every time I got into trouble or
some kind of trouble I just got stronger
like to think or like the blob yeah like
we all know you're so much cooler than
everybody else yeah I just don't you
know I mean just it's uh we had a whole
decide discussion like in the car when
Sophie was here and I said look I just
like to go to a place I like Barbarella
on Saturdays better because it's like I
like to go to a place where I know
pretty much everybody you know a bunch
of randos walking in I can just dance
and not worry about getting groped or
you know scoped on and [__] like that
it's like it's relaxing I like to go I
don't like to go to a place where I'm
constantly having to watch out for
[__] creeps it's not fun for me it's
anxiety inducing and it's like I feel
like I can't relax and I already feel
like I can never relax because I'm
always working so it's like I really
don't like having to be in a place where
I constantly have to be on like guard
looking for people that was just that
one night though that that happened yeah
but there's always douches in there
though yeah I beat them up
yeah and then you're gonna end up in
prison and then I'm going to be stuck in
Sanford nah you know it's like it's
gonna go badly it's gonna go badly it's
gonna be all right
you know you're gonna go there it's
gonna be it's gonna be just like one of
the other nights before where nothing
happened that was just a one-off
it's just you know but it's just like we
had this whole discussion and then like
two days later he's completely forgotten
about it like about what I said I'm
definitely not gonna get run off I don't
let no [__] run me off okay see
I think that's the only reason that he
wants to go back because he's like oh
well I don't want anybody to think that
I'm scared but he doesn't give a [__]
like if I don't want to go or not you
don't have to you don't have to go
I mean I still like I said it's like I
like some of the people that go there I
love big Tom it's just kind of like I
wish that they didn't let those [__]
random [__] people in there yeah are
you going Dave
that would make me feel better if if you
would go he's gone
because then at least I can like yeah
she can trust you to protect I can like
hang out by you
she just thinks I'm gonna turn into the
[__] Tasmanian Devil you probably are
yeah you are going okay good yeah I feel
a little bit better everybody's going
well nobody no hardly anybody was there
last week no this is gonna be like Dave
was there Anna was there like a couple
people we knew yeah that was about it
Debbie there that was about it Annie
will be there
[__] yeah it'll be you'll you'll know
a lot of people there
and [__] man everybody
's stuck together when that [__] went
down
everybody was together
you only got knocked down for a few
seconds
but it's like that's because they maybe
let him go you know they talk you know
Dave says I'll hang with you guys this
time
what's that Pokey who was looking at me
like you are [__] crazy yeah he is
daddy is crazy Poky knows it's not crazy
yeah it is it is not crazy Sebastian
said I thought it was Saturday not
complaining that whoa the show well okay
well we did it Saturday last week
because
um Sophie was here and we went out last
Friday which was the whole incident like
we said on the last live stream and then
we went out again Saturday night so we
moved it so I wouldn't have to rush and
come home and like go out and stuff but
then I this week I rushed and came home
and went out and just like you know what
I mean and I'm sick too on top of it so
that's that's pretty awesome and I don't
want to have cold medicine but I don't
want to take it because you're not
supposed to take it on alcohol because
it'll [__] up your liver but um and
everybody's on the lookout for that dude
if that they're not gonna let him in
he's bad for life all right there's all
these Lookouts
I don't remember what the Dude Looks
Like but if he goes in there I will
instantly know that because somebody
will tell me
all I remember is that Sophie said he
had Jeffrey Dahmer glasses on
that's all and I remember his hair was
long but that's about all that I
remember like I don't really remember
what he looked like because I barely saw
the dude because like I said when he was
kind of like
trying to creep I was just trying not to
look at him because you can't make eye
contacts like I said you make eye
contact and then they start getting
ideas so you always have to like pretend
they're not there man I had I had um
people
diebing me about that dude
and in on the video
and was talking about it yeah I thought
she commented on it because she because
she said oh we were worried that you'd
hit your head and I was like well I did
but not hard yeah like it was mostly my
it was funny because my hand like really
hurt when I came home yeah and then like
after it stopped hurting I was at work
and I was in the bathroom and I looked
at my hand and like it was all green
yeah like it's like it's faded now but
it was like it was all green the other
day like a couple days ago Andy dm'd me
and said that yeah that dude she spit in
his face one time to get rid of him and
it still didn't get rid of him
what's like is he like stupid or yeah he
lives he lives in the area and gets
[__] up and and can't behave
clearly no yeah he gets thrown out
constantly
and then well they still let him back in
though like after he gets thrown out and
then they let him Tom said he's bad for
life
he can't come in okay he did say that
yeah all right
according to Annie I think it was Andy
who said that that he's banned for life
yeah wouldn't it be funny well I don't
know how if this would be funny but like
what if he came back in like a disguise
but like a really bad disguise to
everybody like that it depends like yeah
Like An Inspector Gadget trench coat or
some [__] and a fake mustache
I will call the security even though I'm
twice the size of the security guards
I'd rather have them do it and then if
but if uh well yeah like I said I don't
want you going to jail yeah
I mean you know I ain't gonna fold him
up that bad
he's got to press charges
well yeah he won't be will he won't then
you can press charges on him assaulting
you
yeah I mean I could have of course you
couldn't now that I think about it yeah
I probably I wasn't thinking about it at
the time because I was so that's why I'm
back because that's why he didn't come
back because you could have gotten him
for assault in front of a jury he'd be
[__] toast doing that no I should
have done it yeah there was lots of
witnesses yeah [__] it's probably too
late now isn't it that'd have been
awesome no statute limitations is
probably a couple months probably uh six
months right I might look into that yeah
what if that dude's out there watching
yeah I'm thinking about pressing charges
that'd be cool I was somebody was going
hey man I wouldn't talk about this
assault and this and that man you're
admitting to yourself it's not how it
works a person here has to
um press charges and it would be a bunch
of witnesses against him
and uh you can do in this state you can
do whatever you have to to defend
somebody else so defensive others I was
I was defending Jenny and Soph
yeah no
you get up up to and including deadly
force if you feel that it's necessary if
you think it's necessary I mean I don't
say anybody I don't think he would get
anybody on his side like we're missing
no the whole bar hates you because he
was definitely I got none but thank yous
the Catalyst for that [__] yeah
so yeah apparently I had never seen the
dude before but um apparently other
people told us that he had been creeping
around for a while so everybody was
happy that he got I mentioned it I
mentioned it in the [__]
in that other show man I cannot believe
that these dudes are from a western
country that these are Western men they
don't have any [__] game or no
knowledge of
clubs and Club cultures well it's like
even if you don't like just keep how to
[__] I don't understand like just keep
to yourself it's like why is that hard
like I said I don't understand why
that's so difficult here's the thing
though here's the thing
I don't want
I was I went back and listened to some
of the stuff that I said and I was right
but I was hoping that it I was hoping
that it wouldn't be misinterpreted
I'm not saying that men shouldn't
approach women they should
but if a woman says no you gotta go
you gotta go that's what I mean and I
said that I said that on the show last
week I said I'm not offended by as long
as they're not being creepy or
aggressive or anything like that if they
just come up and very politely like say
oh can I buy you a drink or something
like that I'm not offended by that yeah
but if I say no thank you or something
like that then [__] off like if you hang
around then you're becoming a problem
because that says to me like right there
that you have no understanding of
boundaries and that if I say no to other
things then you are also not going to
listen to me about that so yeah
and that's not something that that I
want to deal with I did many many years
as a single man you know I mean if you
don't approach women you're not going to
get any action
and then women will complain men aren't
approaching us
well the thing is though is second there
they want Chad to approach him or Tyrone
okay it's a certain type of guy that
they want the guys that they like to
approach him and it's up to her whether
or not she thinks you're you're you're
worthy or not you know and
there are some situations where you
could be you could be Chad as [__] and
she's going to say no to you because
she's with a guy or she's with friends
and doesn't want to [__] videos or
she doesn't like chess she just doesn't
like me well no Chad is the guy that you
like that's just generic you know if you
if you think he's you know there's goth
Chads you know
[__] Chad is just like that it just
reminds me yeah it's just a generic
desire some douche and a solo shirt
generic desirable guy yeah like the like
the villain in an 80s High School comedy
you know what I mean like that's kind of
like what that reminds me of like the
jocks and revenge
that's it that makes me think of and I'm
like yeah no thank you no thank you
you're not gonna get anywhere mango says
good evening one and all are we all
sober uh at this moment for right now
right now we are
man my voice sounds really really bad
really really bad I took I stopped at um
Circle K this morning so I could buy
some
cold medicine because I said to myself I
didn't have anything to eat for uh you
know for breakfast like in the house so
I said you know what I'm gonna stop at
Circle K because I could get [__]
cold medicine anyway I said I'm gonna
try out their iced coffee
and I was all excited about it because
you know little things
so I stopped I put ice in the cup and
then I go over to the iced coffee
machine and I go to the mocha one
because all the other one they had was
vanilla and [__] vanilla so it's like so
I put the mocha in there and it was
water with a little bit of coffee and I
was like really really
the one time that I stopped at [__]
Circle K to get an iced coffee and I was
all looking forward to it because I
hadn't had any breakfast and it was
coffee water great yeah so I had to get
vanilla anyway
but it was actually pretty good it
tastes kind of like a frosty what's up
Hernandez well we're gonna get on um
um Blackhawk Down soon
yeah we're gonna talk about that on um
Sunday I've been hearing about that
movie on Sunday's show I hear about that
movie I know that's a good movie and I
haven't seen it man so thank you for
sending that to me that was like a
deluxe issue I think a deluxe edition of
that I think that you sent me that I've
been hearing about that one and then
some other other dudes are saying that I
need to see blood diamonds I've never
seen it oh I saw it is it good um I
remember it being good but uh I saw it
on an airplane all right so I don't know
if I because I think I was flying to
London and I watched it so why do I
watch these [__] heavy ass movies on
planes I don't know yeah but it's you
know takes my mind off it I guess but I
remember it being really good yeah but
it was a long time ago yeah there's a
scene where he's running around it was
it's not leaning another DiCaprio uh
yeah yeah I think it is he's running
around with a damn cult xm177 a little
[__] cult carbine I got one I built
one uh it looks just like it [__]
same Optics and everything
because I liked I always liked the old
xm1770 Colt car 15s I always like those
when I was in service [__] only real
badass units got issued those I was
always lusting off drum so I I did build
my own
but uh
that appears in blood diamonds that that
Carby it's a slightly different version
of it
but because mine has a removable
carrying handle you can't get the fixed
carry handle uppers anymore but
some guys know what I'm talking about
but evidently PSA is coming out where
the whole retro Line kit and one of the
kits is going to be that [__] blood
diamond [__] carving kit
and
with the [__] fixed fixed A1 upper
fixed carry and handle A1 upper
with a skinny pencil Barrel
so that's gonna be good and you know in
PSA you've got reasonable prizes
so uh looking forward to that Jenny has
no idea what I'm talking about
I don't care either she don't give a
[__]
it's not so much I don't know what
you're talking about I just don't care
it's cool [__]
I also heard that God of War is good but
is it supposed to be kind of funny
um it's Nicholas Cage in it yeah yeah
yeah yeah God of War is supposed to be
good I haven't heard much about that but
I mean I have heard a little bit of like
talk about it plays like an
international arms dealer
yeah that's right
Nicholas it's Nicholas Cage in every
movie now yeah he's in all movies I
swear to God like every time I see a new
movie I was like how is Nicholas Cage in
another [__] movie he's got all his
taxes to pay off I know that but it's
like how can you have like time to it's
just like I know this is like kind of
weird but it's like it's just like every
time that I you know go on Hulu or
something and I'm like Gordon Ramsay has
another show on when does the dude
[__] sleep
he can't ever sleep he has like 40
million shows and they're all going like
simultaneously because I just went I
just finished Hell's Kitchen like the
last season of that and then now there's
a new season of Next Level Chef I'm like
when the [__]
Jesus Christ the dude is everywhere I
don't understand how he has time to do
all of this stuff I just don't Louis
says that blood damage is good yeah I
remember it being really good and Zach
said that uh DiCaprio is like does the
best delivery of a South African accent
by us yeah I remember him not
embarrassing himself yeah
not like I'm an expert in South African
accents but you can I'm always like
really
sensitive to when there's an actor that
I know is not of the nationality that
they're portraying and they're doing an
accent so I'm always like really
critical because it's I'm always like
listening for that I'm like you're gonna
[__] it up you're gonna [__] it up
you're gonna [__] it up you know what I
mean so it's always good when they don't
[__] it up but it's much better when
like like we talk about uh a lot like
when we first started watching Walking
Dead and like we didn't I didn't realize
that like a couple of the actors on
there were British so I was like it's
always better when that happens when
it's like actors that are not the
nationality they're portraying but that
you don't know you know what I mean and
it's like you can't tell that it's
because I couldn't tell the difference
until like later on
and I was like oh yeah once you know
like then you can kind of pick at it but
I didn't the worst of all times was
Keanu Reeves his British and I love
Kiana yeah he's great man [__] hey uh
first of all he's a good man he's a good
dude he seems like the nicest dude
imaginable which is awesome which is us
he's I have never heard a single person
to play like oh he's an [__] or
anything like that never everybody likes
him everybody just thinks he's the
sweetest dude ever he [__] knows
motorcycles he had his own little
motorcycle company knows everything
about the history of motorcycles big
into him and another thing if people
don't realize is Reeves can [__]
shoot man I've seen him at uh close
quarter combat ranges and he's a [__]
great [__] he's great with a weapon
real good
now what he's training for is kind of
not realistic multiple targets at close
range and [__] just popping up and
he would never survive anything like
that but he's just got good shooting
reflexes he's real good very natural
I wouldn't [__] with him
he's good
and that's you know usually actors
aren't any good although I gotta say Tom
Cruise is good with a gun and a
motorcycle and an aircraft even though
he's kind of cheesy
he can deliver
and I still haven't seen Maverick
everybody said it was great
yeah I mean you know the longer it goes
like without us seeing it the less
enthusiastic I am about it well like I
said I didn't realize streaming it yet I
didn't really like the first Top Gun all
that much yeah yeah it was kind of
generic I didn't like it well like I
said it was just very cheesy it had that
whole like 80s rah-rah like super cheesy
kind of when I was just like man it
wasn't that exciting it's just like
super cringy it wasn't that exciting
either I mean it's funny like it's funny
because it's kind of like homoerotic
without really seeming to realize that
it's homoerotic I think they did well I
don't know if the actors realized it I'm
sure the screenwriters realize
right I think they just thought it was
funny that like everybody yeah we didn't
make this [__] gay as [__] flying
through the air [__] playing
volleyball
yeah yeah I mean seriously all right
guys [__] rub that oil yourselves up
yeah come on take your shirts off well
yourself
straight as [__] okay
super Superman like straight as [__]
super manly yeah
Louie says Maverick is on Paramount plus
is it oh yeah maybe I should get that
there's a lot of good [__] on there
what did I say I was gonna get the other
day because it had um Megan on it oh
peacock premium yeah I think
um somebody said that they gave it was
that David Dave said that he would give
us yeah he's got a password
I mean I think it's only five dollars a
month I think but I mean I don't know
it's not that how like how many [__]
streaming services do I pay for
I don't pay for Netflix anymore you pay
for Netflix but I think I pay for I have
my own Amazon Prime I pay for shutter I
pay for Hulu
um I pay for HBO Max I mean that's tied
in with my phone plan but still my phone
plan is 65 or something brick box is
only 2.99. yeah because it's just an
add-on yeah yeah
I keep meaning until look on there and
see because I love like British shows
and stuff I got those little British
shows even got the goodies on there from
back in the 70s holy [__] yeah hey do
they have the young ones on there I
think they do I think they do I might
have to re-watch those like the young
ones in the comic strip I that was one
thing that I meant to look for because I
haven't seen those instructions I have
absolutely fabulous on there oh that's
good too I love absolutely fabulous
have you did you watch it yeah oh my God
that was so [__] funny yeah
yeah I realized I had a friend that used
to um
that used to tape it for me back in the
old days when there was what was that
for you British people what was the one
where they were uh it was in the 70s it
was about a bunch of people working in a
department store are you being served
are you being served that [__] was
[__] funny I know that's like old
school yeah old school [__] that [__]
was funny [__] another one that was good
was a Dad's Army oh yeah that was good
too these old codgers [__] in the
British like their version of like the
reserves or or not even the reserves
like the auxiliary reserves they're just
old veterans like in their 70s and 80s
back in England and World War II and I
think they were just doing things like
Manning searchlights and [__] like that
you know just the the funny [__] that
they were doing
funny [__] yeah I kind of remember
seeing it well because
um
I kind of I watched all those kind of
like old British shows because like you
know I used to be married to a British
person and so like he showed me all of
the
like old [__] that he had grown up
watching
um now one of the ones that is that was
still really funny was Only Fools and
Horses I don't know if you've ever seen
that but that's like super funny but um
he also showed me like Steptoe and Son
which is what our show Stanford and son
was based on which I think a lot of
people don't know that that was based on
a British show but it was okay but um
but yeah it was like a similar thing
where I think they worked in it like it
was a junkyard right yeah because I
remember my grandma used to live it was
a house that had it was selling junk
through it yeah yeah so like a junkyard
like yeah it was the size of a house at
the yard out in front I want to take a
joke when I'm thinking of a junkyard I'm
thinking of like many acres like 50
acres of junk it wasn't that it was it
was in a neighborhood
it was a salvage place
yeah it's been a long time
I just remember like watching it because
my grandma and grandpa were always
watching it so I remember it always
being on at my grandparents house that
and they were they they always watch
that and like The Jeffersons yeah and um
what else did they watch all the time I
kind of feel like they watched all the
like [__]
good times and
[__] now I can't remember like all those
[__] chairs they used to watch in the
70s hahaha
you're in there talking about James Bond
you know slash your friends talking
about Benny Hill oh yeah we have Benny
Hill like I saw it in the 70s like we
had it on the weird thing is that we had
you know PBS like a lot of PBS stations
would show a lot of old British stuff
let's say they'd show like Benny Hill or
Doctor Who or
um are you being served or what was that
other one like good neighbors or good
what the [__] was the name of that yeah
that really Tweety one I know I don't
remember in the early 80s they'd play
Benny Hill on television yeah yeah
California
I don't know if that was a nationwide
but I think and I think it was on PBS I
think they played it on PBS yeah that's
what I just said yeah
I think I think Benny Hill actually made
made me a boob freak I think because I
think that was my first exposure to
porn-like material they'd have those
damn
stripper tight he's gonna see all the
rubies yeah yeah and they're [__]
they'd have little clips for this
[__] dancing and that just took up
his whole entire brain and that's it
earlier it got infused earlier and then
they were what was so funny is that
Betty Hill was getting all this [__]
Flack you know everyone's about being
some kind of a sexist and [__] like that
but actually no evidently he was like
real um
um mild-mannered and um kind of a simpy
and was making fun of his own simpiness
and I think he lived alone
in in by American Standards very humble
house
and uh
the way he looked at it is that he was
making fun of his own inadequacy around
women
making you know joking of how him and
the other dudes were so [__] simpy
well see that's the thing I kind of feel
like
comedy is
sort of difficult to do because there's
like a fine line between I think about
this a lot because I think that I was
thinking about it in terms of like
Mystery Science Theater because some
people were kind of like well there's a
fine line between making fun of
something and making fun of the
attitudes about that something you know
what I mean like it's kind of like
um for example like I kind of feel like
back in the 90s or the 2000s like
sometimes on MST they would make like a
lot of kind of like gay jokes but they
weren't make they weren't necessarily
making fun of gay people they were
making fun of people's attitudes then
about towards it so it's like it's a
subtle distinction but it's a pretty
important distinction yeah you know what
I mean today they would just paint it
with a broad brush saying it's
homophobic well I mean they did back
then too it's just I mean you know it's
that's nothing new but I'm just saying
that you really have to like you have to
look at the way that the comedy is
constructed because a lot of times
they're not making fun of you know the
marginalized person or whatever they're
making them the reaction they're making
fun of the reaction to them or like the
you know the way that people react to
them so like I said it's kind of a
subtle distinction but it's one that
people kind of need to because you know
comedy is a lot more subtle than people
give it credit for I guess I think
there's people that a lot of people that
are under a certain
IQ number that can't grasp comedy very
well they they're offended by it because
they don't they can't see they can't
detect the like they said they can't
detect the nuances in there right well a
lot of people can't detect Nuance in a
lot of things yeah and I think that's an
issue but
um but yeah and particularly in comedy
you really can't
because you can make fun of something
but not like in a mean-spirited way you
know what I mean even though it kind of
sounds means but I don't know it's like
I feel like I'm not explaining it right
but you know what I'm saying yeah you
know what I'm saying
[Laughter]
um wait let me see who would you rather
hang with Benny Hill or Benny Hinn well
that's an easy question
is Benny Hinn still alive I don't know
who that is that sounds like a cook no
he's that television he's that
evangelist he used to be on TV all the
time and he had this [__] crazy ass
hair and it was gray and it was like
swooped over like like that yeah he was
all the Billboards and stuff and he was
the one that would just be like and like
knock the people I know I guess a lot of
them did that but I think that was like
kind of what he was famous for tell
evangelists are entertainers he might be
dead now I cannot understand how anybody
could take them seriously there a lot of
people do that which blows my [__]
obviously entertainers I kind of want to
do a show about that but yeah like about
television because I used to back in the
90s I used to get really I was really
um
I was I kind of hate watched some of
them because I because I couldn't
believe yeah I was like people really
take this [__] seriously the one that
I watched most I saw some of Benny Hinn
but he was kind of boring because no he
would just normally like knock people
over and I'm just like okay whatever
that's a plan but um the one that was
interesting to me because he was so
freaky and so obviously like a charlatan
what I mean they all are but he was very
obviously a charlatan was um what was
his name Robert Tilton yeah yeah too
um and he would just like be on the show
and he his big thing was and this blows
my mind that people fell for this but
they did Millions people did
um he would say well you have to give
out of your need right like in other
words like send me money and then God
will reward you by giving you money you
are needy and poor but if you send me
your money God will make you rich that's
what he's saying yeah it's like it's
Prosperity Gospel which is to me that's
like atrocious because you're just like
targeting the most vulnerable people
that don't have the money and maybe
don't have the intelligence or the
wherewithal to like not
send you like their last [__] ten
dollars that they dated for groceries
late in Charlotte I mean it's like I
don't know how they can sleep at night
that's awful I just like couldn't do
that I just couldn't do that to people I
remember I used to watch Tammy Faye
Baker and I really want to do a show
about that yeah we got to do shoes I
think I put it in the poll but it didn't
win but it's like I I'll put it in the
poll again I really do want to do a show
about those too they were obviously fake
obviously I still want to see that movie
The Eyes of Tammy Faye I was a I was a
teenager [__] watch I'd go through
that and that'd be on like some of the
channels that was what channel was That
on it was on some of the cable channels
but they were like there was a channel
called it was like a term PTL praise the
praise the Lord that's right PTO that's
right
PTSD whatever yeah
you might be up at three o'clock in the
morning and nothing's on and then right
yeah back in the day like nothing was on
you turn that [__] on and you'd [__]
goof on that seven infomercials and
televangelists and I was looking at
Tammy face fat little face man
she was cute actually when she was young
she was cute she had this fat little
face she looked like a hamster and she
was Tiny
with these huge [__] eyelashes well
yeah I kind of feel like she piled them
on yeah yeah yeah and because I don't
even know if they make fake eyelashes
just custom eyelashes or something man
that was some [__] she got I think she
just put some on and then glued some
onto the end and glued some onto the
edge she got that [__] from the hooker
shop all right I mean they do have big
ones now yeah but [__] from the hooker
shot
and then like her husband would come out
and I was I was just in disbelief you
know what I mean that people could take
this seriously it was obviously
entertainment to me
you know I was like no you know what I
mean they're full of [__] and I was
looking at Tammy Faye and I was I
remember being like I don't know
17-18 and I'm going I bet you that
chick's a freak
and I was looking at her yeah yeah I bet
that [__] is a total [__] friend
looking at her husband I'm going and I'm
going like I'm like she's not just
[__] him she's [__] some other
dudes too
and maybe also some other species I
wouldn't like to speculate he was
[__]
what was his name Jim Baker he was
[__] that
chick that ended up being a porn star
later on was it Han
yeah why do I remember that holy [__]
that was his secretary she was fine yeah
yeah but when you saw him coming out of
the airplanes and they were being
outside the church in this Entourage
it's obvious that this is not a an
ecclesiastical [__] unit okay these
are [__] entertainers well yeah and
it's just hard to believe that they
found it
enough gullible people to keep them in
business they had a lot of money they
didn't get a [__] ton of money it just
it makes me sad it makes me sad that
well one that people would be that
shitty to like take advantage of people
like that but because like I said I
can't do something like that but it's
like they they don't even give a [__]
about these people and it's I don't know
it just makes me sad that like people
would actually like oh I only have like
you know ten dollars left for this week
and I gotta buy diapers for the baby but
it's like I'm gonna send it to these
[__] who already have like 50
bajillion dollars in airplanes and [__]
like that and like they think that's
gonna help them and that's like really
sad I never met Tammy Faye don't know
anything about Tabby Faye Baker but I
guarantee you my [__] [__] detection
[__] my [__] detection abilities were
[__] honed by the time I was 18 or
19. and I just and I looked at that
woman and I said man that chick is a
[__] total [__] I could tell I could
[__] tell well and probably a good
one not a bad one a good one she was
probably a good one probably been a lot
of fun
because they had nothing to they were
not religious they were not religious
that was that was awesome they're just
taking advantage yeah something that
like makes a lot of money she would have
been
if she wasn't in that church making all
that money she'd have been a porn star
guarantee you
I kind of feel like a lot of those kind
of people are freaks
Yeah because sometimes they feel guilty
about being a freak so it's like they go
like way in the other direction at least
in public you know what I mean because
they're like hiding something I think
Jim Baker surrounded himself with [__]
that could disguise themselves as
religious people because that was their
that was their stick that was their
business yeah probably Behind Closed
though he's laughing their asses
laughing their asses off slapping each
other in the ass having [__] rolling
around in piles of money
all this [__] about Tammy not knowing
about Jessica and [__] no no that's not
how that went that's not how that
happened
what happened is the cover got blown and
she tried to probably keep the business
she wanted to keep the business he got
defrocked yeah so she had to play like
oh I don't know nothing about this right
she's had to like I'm the good ones
yourself right
that's what she was trying to do she
knew
she knew I mean I feel like it would be
hard enough that was probably a
threesome that's what I was gonna say
yeah she was probably in on that [__]
Hugo said comedy is very difficult I
think it's easier to make horror yeah
horror is hard too but I think comedy is
probably harder although comedy and
horror are actually really really
similar and usually people that are
really really good at comedy also make
really really good horror movies too
because it's a similar
um and I know it sounds weird but it's
like it's a similar setup I mean it's
all about kind of like build up of
tension and then release you know what I
mean it's just like in comedy obviously
it's you know you build up and build up
and then you get a laugh and then horror
you build up and then you just get a
scare but it's kind of the same thing
and like a lot of the um same principles
apply so like I said that's kind of why
comedians usually make good horror
movies
um Zach says isn't it a thing where
hookers say the biggest freaks are the
super uptight businessman types yeah I
kind of feel like anybody that's one
thing I've heard I don't know if it's
true I don't have any statistics on this
but I have heard
that
um real like high-powered business
people that have little like high stress
jobs or they like are in charge of like
a lot of stuff they're subbed yeah they
like to be Subs like they like to go to
um to sex workers and just be like made
them make them drink out of the toilet
and like wear dog collars and be
humiliated and stuff like that because I
guess it's like a relief I get it like
I'm trying to unburdened themselves
right that damn responsibility somebody
else like somebody else is in charge
like it's totally yeah I mean that makes
total sense like you know what I mean so
I'm not you know I'm not saying that's
weird or anything yeah absolutely saying
we got to do one on um Jimmy Jimmy
Swagger Jimmy Swagger and all that
forgive me I have sinned I remember when
that [__] happened he got caught with
all the hookers they're they no man I
mean if they either get caught with
hookers or child yeah or something yeah
had he not been caught none of that
would happen it would just sort of
continued on like it was because that's
who he really was those dudes are not
religious they were entertainers
yeah which I you know and I just find it
funny that people would even consider
believing a televangelist a TV
evangelist like I said it just makes me
so sad it made me so sad I think that
was maybe the reason that I hate watch
that [__] so much like on TV
like Robert Sultan you know like in the
middle of the night when I couldn't
sleep because he would have let I don't
you know I'm sure these were real
Letters by other people setting because
people sending money and stuff so he
would like open the letters and you know
read them and it was just like the
saddest [__] ever like these people were
talking about how [__] broke they
were and all this other stuff and this
is my last one twenty dollars about and
I'm like don't send this [__]
your last 20 and it's like what's he
gonna do he's gonna sit there on TV and
he had these little things that were
like what the [__] were they like little
prayer cloths yeah they're just like
little pieces of paper that you cut out
with pinking shears or some [__] like
that and he's like it just put it
between his hands and I'm praying for
you and you're you're gonna get all this
money in your mailbox and stuff because
it was in the 90s like we didn't have
the internet yet right and so like you
know you'd get money in the mail
and then you know and then sometimes
he'd have what I'm sure were probably
fake
um testimonial type things where people
were like yeah I sent you my last ten
dollars and then I won the lottery or
some [__] like that you know yeah so
they were all fake uh yeah I'm sure they
were I mean it's like maybe there was
one that was real that was like a total
coincidence but I'm sure that nothing
like most of the time 99 of the time
that's just fake if you go back and look
at any of that [__] you'll see how
scripted and how controlled those
broadcasts were
there was no there was no error nothing
left to chance
every one of those letters written in by
a person they were a fake letter it was
a way of building up confidence in the
viewer yeah that they would call in the
on the phone and make a donation that's
all it was yeah they
they would just make up all those
letters
the whole thing was an illusion
what they call it's a con job yeah it's
a con job
Mr 88 said the worst was Ted Haggard oh
yeah I remember that dude he was
president of the National Association of
evangelicals and was caught habitually
buying meth and spending a lot of time
with gay escorts yeah you cannot write
this stuff
yeah yeah and usually like I said the
more that people come out and you know
rail against gay people and rail against
this that and the other you know they're
doing suspect you know they're doing
that anybody who's worried about that
there's some suspect [__] going on
projection yeah but what
when it comes to guys like that when
we're talking about televangelists they
have to start off as a sociopath all
right well you have to be you have to be
to just like [__] people over like that
without caring about it and sociopaths
have certain uh well they don't have
of course everything is a mask and they
don't care about breaking any rules they
don't care about lying they're they're
under no stress when it comes to lying
they put them on a damn lie detector and
they don't show any [__] stress
uh because this is just natural to them
well because they don't care about other
people they don't care that the other
person knows that they're lying right I
don't give a [__] right and then uh so
that makes you perfect for a job like
that yeah well sociopath is not going to
be doing [__] honestly in his private
life he's not doing anything honest in
his business life but it's definitely
not gonna be his private life so if he's
a pedo he's doing that you know if he's
gay he's doing that if he you know he'll
just do anything you know it doesn't
matter
because uh it's all a lie anyway there's
no concept of
look I'm portraying one thing in public
making all this money shouldn't I feel
bad that I'm portraying a False Image no
no not in their thinking well they don't
think they don't have a conscience no
conscious and they're thinking it's just
like oh no you know
if they want to send me money for my
lies then that's no one's making them no
one's making them do it right yeah
that's what that's what they're doing
even though they're completely
portraying like a complete false yeah
totally false right and it's like and we
can't really like I said I don't want to
lean too hard on like blaming the
victims because some people you know
let's not be mean but like some people
aren't that smart or they're not that
educated or they really really really
want to believe it you know what I mean
so I'm not gonna [__] on those people
for like oh well you shouldn't be so
dumb to like send your [__] to that
person but it's like I just kind of feel
like I I you know they have to be
sociopaths oh yeah they have to
definitely and people go like well you
can't have a big organization like that
and all those crazy people at the top
and I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about yes you can [__] uh
once that environment's set up it'll
just attract every sociopath will run
towards it like The Guiding Light and
that whole organization will be a bunch
of lying [__]
lion two-faced [__] and they're
because they're making money yeah but
you know when nobody's looking they'll
tell each other the truth yeah we're
gonna make some money off these [__]
dumb asses you know well yeah that's
just they just think it's they're a
bunch of rooms a bunch of rooms yep
that's all yeah so like I said that just
makes me sad because it's shitty
I think that's in most Industries I
think most corporations
is definitely like that uh politics is
all imitation it's like it's like
[__] the WWE or something you know
what I mean they're they're pretending
to be enemies they're making money the
corporations have them in their pockets
so deep they just they just sit up there
and make money and it's a fake job
they don't really do anything that's why
back it never spend that way for
thousands of years in these [__]
republics that's why a Roman Emperor
would do some [__] like make a horse his
[__]
a senator
that was just his way of saying Senators
don't do anything even a horse could be
a senator they didn't do anything they
sat around collected money and married
teenage girls that's what they did in
ancient row
and then they get pissed you know the
emperor would go y'all are [__]
spinning up the [__] Treasury and
everything on all these young women
we're going to make all these young
hookers and they're all ex-hookers that
they're marrying a lot of them we're
gonna put them in the brothels where
they belong and work off the [__]
debt that you guys are [__] making I
forgot what what emperor did that I
think it might have I don't think it
might have been Caligula
well just because you know you had 60
year old dudes marrying [__] 14 year
old [__]
girls out of the brothels that's what
they were doing
Mr 88 said when your target audience is
defined by believing in a magic man and
the sky icon is not too difficult yeah I
mean you know
it's just kind of like I think that was
also the reason I think I brought this
up before but I think that was also the
reason I was kind of fascinated by the
whole um you know spiritualism boom and
like all the seances and like all the
tricks that they did and like the sad
thing was that some people and this is
like I don't know this is really sad to
me because I guess some people were just
so desperate to talk to their dead loved
ones
that it didn't matter
you know all you know Houdini and all
these other kind of people that went and
exposed all these mediums and it's like
look they're doing this and that and the
truck you know and people were like oh
well that one's fake but then maybe this
one is real you know what I mean and
it's just kind of like wasn't it I think
it was Carl Sagan that called like
people believed and I think it was Carl
Sagan that called people that believed
like that Unsinkable rubber ducks
because it's like even if you like tell
them
even if you expose like I said like
Houdini exposed like a whole bunch of
mediums and like showed all the tricks
they did he replicated all their tricks
all his and magicians have been doing it
like all they can do like all the tricks
that psychics do and stuff like that but
it's like still people still believe in
it it's like oh well this one is real
though even though all of their tricks
can be replicated by a magician all of
them and have been multiple times but
it's like some people just want to
believe it so bad number eight uh you're
talking about we you know the Magic Man
In The Sky [__]
the televangers that we're talking about
their target audience
which actually would have been like
people like my grandmother
you know they were they weren't Our
Generation
and somebody you know an older woman in
her 70s or [__] 80s living in
probably a trailer somewhere in the
South or a very small house out in the
south
um
husband you know she's a widow uh not
many family members left and they're
just you know they're just waiting to go
to the big [__]
party in the sky waiting to check out
and they're just [__] listening to
some televangelists that they have the
hots for okay he's a sex symbol to him
and uh they're sending him some money so
their soul can go to heaven type of deal
so they can feel good about himself
that's what they were doing that's what
the same thing with that remember that
[__] auction Channel QVC I think yeah
it's still on isn't it yeah maybe I
don't know that's all that was that's
just lonely lonely old ladies yeah
because they would like call in and
they'd just be like talk and tell your
whole life story while they were like
trying to buy a [__] juicer or some
[__] yeah it's kind of like no one cares
about your life story Grandpa yeah I
know that's mean but it's like come on
lonely lonely old ladies watching
television well it's things that they
see I'm gonna say it's like I hate you
know I hate to say but it's like kind of
maybe like the boomer generation or like
earlier it's like you go because I used
to get this sometimes too like when I
worked in a print shop and everything
like that like you'd get like these old
dudes and they would like come in and
it's like they would you know they'd
need something printed or something you
know notarized or something and then
they would come in and then they'd want
to talk for like hours and hours and
hours and then they would just like
start [__] ranting about this and
that and the other thing about politics
and it's just I'm just like dude um
we're at work we know this is a store
this is a store we have like
we can't just like stand here and listen
to you all day long it's like not to be
an [__] but [__] yeah well I mean
it's kind I guess it's sad that they
don't have like a social no social
network and stuff like that but it's
like I don't know I guess it's hard for
me to like understand because I'm kind
of like well you know I'm kind of like
well one I'm kind of like an introverted
person and it's like if there's nobody
around to talk to I don't really give a
[__] it's like I'll just talk to myself
I'll show you it's fine the internet but
um you can make comments on videos or
interact with people all over the world
so
yeah they don't know how old you are so
you know what I mean you could you could
be an old man and you could be
commenting to people they'd respond to
you right they don't know how old you
are
you could have a whole virtual alternate
personality you know a catfish is what
they call it you know [__] going
doing [__] through an avatar you know
nobody knows nobody knows you're 80. but
they would know that generation
our generation will probably be able to
pull it off for better 70s and 80s
[Laughter]
it's like that's super funny well people
aren't quite aging the same way yeah
we've talked about it's kind of like
fascinating we were talking about it a
little bit
like because like I said when Sophie was
here last week yeah um I guess it didn't
occur to me but she's
31 young enough to be our kid which like
I I was like oh yeah yeah I said I don't
really think about it but then I was
thinking oh yeah I could be her mom
that's pretty weird yeah but um I guess
but uh she says we are nothing like her
parents so she doesn't have that right
she doesn't have that feeling about us
but well and that's what we were telling
her like when we you know we took her to
mannequins on Friday night and that
whole [__] happened but then we took her
to Barbarella on Saturday night which is
um you know that's the 80s night and
it's a much older crowd so it's a lot
more chill like I said we had me and
Sophie had like a much better time
because you know we knew everybody and
yeah you could just be civilized you
could just dance and like everybody was
just like whatever man and like everyone
was happy and it's just like everyone's
just having a good time like nobody was
being a [__] yeah nobody gay guys
over here and then you got the straight
people over here and then some young
people came in everything everybody
[__] knows everybody and it's just
yeah it's a whole crowd that comes there
like every Saturday and every really
knows everybody and everybody they wait
all week like to just go there and dance
to like some good 80s [__] and like some
Post Punk and stuff and so everybody's
just in a good mood and you know so it's
so it's a nice it's a nice Vibe and like
Sophie was saying that to me too in the
bathroom she's like God the vibe is like
so much nicer in here because everybody
knows everybody and yeah you know
everybody's old friends they've known
each other forever and so it's you know
it was like a lot nicer but it's she's
like that's okay she's like I would
rather hang out with like a bunch of 50
and 60 year olds that were chill and
just were there to listen to music then
hang out with a bunch of people her age
that were like you know [__] they had
a lot of people they had people younger
than 50 though yeah I know I'm just
saying I was just making like
generalization yeah there are like
younger people there was a girl in her
20s went out there [__] ass hanging
out through the bottom of her shorts
remember her yeah yeah she wasn't around
very long well that's what's weird too
and I never can't tell what's gonna
happen me and Sophie were talking about
this because she likes a lot a lot of
80s music now she doesn't know some of
it because you know what I mean she
wasn't alive back then so it's like she
missed out on some stuff so she's always
kind of like asking about everything but
um you know it's her she likes a lot of
the goth that came out like the 90s
which like I said by that time I had
already been like yeah I don't really
like that as much but um
some of it was okay yeah but I didn't
like the real mainstreamy stuff like
after it started going mainstreaming and
it's like like London after midnight
well yeah yeah I like that stuff there
was there was good [__] going on but it
wasn't like the Nine Inch Nails that you
know in Man City and I don't like that
kind of stuff but um so yeah so we were
talking about it and she said
she's like well I think because I I was
like I don't I'm not sure if it's bad
it's like I think that nowadays because
of the internet because it's so easy to
access music from all eras I kind of
feel like music to a large extent has
become disconnected from its era yeah um
in a way that it never had been you know
what I mean because I kind of feel like
people had nostalgic feelings about oh
this song came out and I think people
still have that but now it's like it's
so easy to just like listen to a song on
Spotify or whatever and you don't know
what [__] year that came out you're
just like oh that's a good song Whatever
it could be from like 1955 or it could
be from like a minute ago you know I
mean you don't really know so I think
that in a way I think that's good but
then I was talking to her
and I was like in a way though I kind of
feel like and she was agreeing with me
about that this too is she's like well a
lot of times too like you don't she's
like a lot of songs I like from the 80s
like I don't have the cultural context
of what they were talking about in that
song or what was going on at the same
time that that song came out and she's
like so I like to kind of like research
that a little bit because I said it's
really funny because I was driving home
from work and I'd have my Spotify on and
they played um it was like Rock the
Casbah or something like that and I said
to myself and I I thought this I was
like you know if people listen to that
song now like it's a great song but it's
like you wouldn't know what they were
talking what they were talking about
necessarily because that came out in
like 1982 and like the world situation
was different and [__] like that and
then we started talking about
um like how 80s music because one of the
one of my favorite things about 80s
music is that I love that there was like
a whole thing where they did like all
these like super poppy dance songs that
were all about like nuclear Annihilation
language at like a nola gay and like uh
99 red balloons and all that kind of
stuff and it's like I just thought that
I just like that juxtaposition that's
always like hilarious apocalyptic stuff
right it was all like kind of like that
and it's it's funny because like as soon
as we were talking about that because I
was talking about 99 Red Balloons and I
said do you know the song Enola Gay uh
by OMD and she's like yeah probably and
then like like five minutes later like
they played it which is really weird and
I was like yeah
because that would probably be a Logical
Song to come up next in the play
playlist yeah because there are certain
songs that sound like the next song and
then right so you probably your
subconscious was probably like I bet you
know the gay is coming up maybe but like
I said that's how computers are [__]
really good uh DJs yeah it knows how
many beats per minute it knows all this
all kinds of [__] about the song it
knows what to put next but it's because
but that's always one of the examples
that I give of like 80s music that it's
like really poppy songs about
the end of the world there was a lot of
that but that was kind of one of the
main ones because we were in the Cold
War right yeah and that's why it's like
you know it's not the same we were being
told that the world could end at any
minute and it probably could have but it
wasn't going to
I served in the military during the very
end of the Cold War saw the fall of the
Soviet Union
and once you start getting into the
military industrial complex you realize
that this Soviet Empire and the American
Empire were kind of like in a they were
in a synergetic relationship they kind
of needed each other
and the Soviets were good they were real
good they were real disciplined guys
they they followed the orders that their
commanders gave them and their
commanders were telling them you know
hey look don't shoot anybody you know
they're here's where the border is don't
cross the border that kind of [__] and a
lot of it was in the sky you know too
you know and you know the two sides that
duel it out in aircraft but they never
shoot at each other they're just waving
dicks at each other really you know I
got you [__] and then they'd salute and
[__] leave
because both sides had to be real uh
professional or you could kick off a
nuclear war
and uh the Russians the Russians and the
the Russians and just the Soviet Empire
in general were professional guys they
were good real good
Michelle Jarvis says I'm new you are
awesome well thank you thanks and
welcome
Sebastian says I thought 99 Red Balloons
was about Alien Invasion no no it's
actually about an accidental yeah
nuclear war is what it's about like
somebody like a kid is in the story of
it like a kid releases like accidentally
releases like a bunch of Red Balloons
into the sky and then like somebody sees
it and thinks it's like a warning that
oh [__] the other side launch nukes so
now we're gonna launch nukes well the
that's the story right
I don't really know the English version
of the song Too Well because the
original is German
it's 99 red Luft balloons
it's 99 luftable 99 lift balloons yeah
yeah yeah and I pretty much I like the
German version better that's they're
both good that's when I grew up I mean
it's the same chick doing them it's not
like somebody it wasn't like a Falco
after the fire situation with your
commissar with like another band doing
this yeah the German the German the
commissar is [__] great I don't know
I like the English language one the
Falco one's good too yeah poor old Falco
did he get did he get run over by a car
like it was a long time ago yeah
I still like Rock Me Amadeus like
completely unironically yeah but
he had some good songs like he did one
called what the [__] was the name it was
kind of like a slow song I think it was
called Gene
and uh I had the single like way back in
the day like back in the 80s or whenever
the [__] that came out but that was like
a good song
um
yeah I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
like I don't know all the words
I know most of the words but I'm pretty
sure the story of it is that a kid
releases a bunch of Red Bull 99 Red
Balloons into the air and like somebody
sees them like some high muckety muck
sees them and thinks that that means
it's like a signal that like the other
people launch their nuke so it's like
well we have to launch our nukes because
it's it's on like it's popping off so
then the whole world is blown up and
then at the very end of the song like
the whole world is annihilated and then
there's like one red balloon like
[__]
like floating up into the sky which
always seemed like a very poignant image
to me
you know what I mean for like like I
said for like a
a pop song that probably just like a lot
of people dance to or like listen to on
the radio or something and don't know
what it means that's what I think why
80s like New Wave Music is so funny to
me because like a lot and like so cool
is that it's like stealth depressing
like it doesn't sound depressing like it
sounds like really Poppy and awesome and
like you can just Bop around to it in
the car like whatever and then like but
if you actually listen to the lyrics
you're like holy [__]
this is messed up but yeah it's like a
lot of the songs are [__] like that
it's like yeah it's this poppy song
called Enola Gay and it's about like the
[__] bombs being dropped on Nagasaki
you know it's like that's [__] up and
it's like and I and I love that I just
love that juxtaposition
um Falco predicted digital only currency
and Rock Me Amadeus
oh yeah
I haven't heard that song in such a long
time
what is
wait did he do an English language
version of that or was there only a
German version
of Rock Me Amadeus now I can't remember
I think it was a German version too I
think well now I'm saying I know the
German version I don't know if there I
mean I'm sure that there was anything oh
you think it was an English version yeah
was there an English version I only know
the German version
uh Mr 88 said yeah listen to the lyrics
of little girls by Oingo Boingo yeah
that's another one that's another good
one I like one good boy and girl yeah
he's making fun of petos yeah I mean
yeah but like I said I kind of like that
about the 80s that it's just like these
poppy songs about really dark [__] Danny
elfman's dad was a naval Admiral I think
he grew up kind of in a military family
he uh he knew what was up
I remember that [__] album was it
nothing to fear man that was a [__]
great album
or it might have just been called fear I
think it was called nothing to fear I
think
Mr 80 it said also said uh Every Breath
You Take is like a soundtrack for
stalking yeah yeah and I remember seeing
I don't know why I remember this so
vividly it was supposed to be I remember
well no I remember saying an interview
with sting yeah where he said that um
he said that people get married to this
song and he's just like talking about
okay
uh he's like that's not what that song
is like the song is like [__] up it's
about a stalker yeah I mean it's about a
stalker yeah it's not romantic it sounds
romantic just on this just superficially
and the Beat
the beat part nice melody
but no he's talking about a dude who
wants total control over a woman yeah
everywhere you go yeah everywhere you
I'm watching you yeah it was scary she's
like I can't believe that [__] because
that was like totally unintended
unintended it says that is a very
unhealthy yeah [__] thing and it was
supposed to be that's a [__] up so he
came out with a response to that on a
dream of the blue turtles called if you
love someone yeah and that became a hit
too it's another great song that is a
good song yeah it's not as good as Every
Breath You Take but it's still pretty
good they're all good man the [__]
police were good and some of Sting solo
stuff was good memorable [__] that is
sufferable [__] he's not as
insufferable as bonus yeah was much
worse I had dream of the blue Turtles
um but I think that was the last sting
album that I bought yeah
Zach says um by the way this one's for
Tom I have an action movie idea about
soldiers in a PMC rescuing someone
figured you'd know how that [__] works
you know what PMC he says PMC
uh yeah I don't know that acronym that
must be newer than my time we didn't
have that in my time
is that I don't know what branch you're
in uh the Army didn't have that so it's
wet now it's it's guys rescuing somebody
in a PMC yeah
he's an idea he has for a movie like an
okay
well if he tells us maybe he does what
he is I don't know what you're talking
about Mr 88 said we were happy in the
80s well obviously I wasn't but you know
I'm just not a happy person in general
the only group that paid huge attention
to lyrics was satanic Panic folk and you
know
that person but
like because not like I was gonna get
like all offended about it just because
I'm like interested in lyrics a lot of
the satanic Panic people though [__]
totally misunderstood lyrics yeah no
[__] they would go into [__] Judas
Priest and think it was [__] Judas
Priest songs I think it was satanic
there's nothing satanic about Judas
Priest nothing
it was leather daddy [__] that's what
they missed they were [__] straight
they couldn't understand the lingo he
didn't know what the island of
domination what Fire Island was you know
what I'm talking about they didn't know
I find it hard to believe that they
didn't know what Fire Island what I
thought everybody knew about the whole
connotation okay Fire Island that look
there's it's just me too much fantastic
fantastic Judas Priest album back in the
70s one of my favorite ones it's called
sin after sin
and on there is a is a [__] song
called Raw Deal
and Raw Deal is about
Rob going somewhere near Fire Island and
he goes he makes us he makes the spike
about nine o'clock on a Saturday
and he goes there and he said all eyes
were all eyes were on me as I walked
into the bar it says there were leather
cops like well wait a minute what and
the leather Cops playing rough stuff
it was all kinds of [__] there was I
mean obviously bodies [__] gyrating
to the action they were flying he was
having they were [__] him up he was
having an out of body experience to the
whole thing just re he never printed the
lyrics because that that album didn't
have any lyrics in it
people thought that [__] Rob Halford
came out in the 90s all right no Rob
Alford came out in the [__] 70s you
just had to pay attention to the lyrics
he was never closeted it's obvious he's
just looking at his performances he's a
leather daddy
now when I first tried to go through all
those I was a teenager I couldn't quite
grasp what he was talking about but
later I was like okay yeah I don't know
he's talking about he's talking about
the leather scene
yeah I mean when you say it out loud
he made the spike what else
yeah they all looked at he said he
smacked us he says in fact they said the
bartender came up came up a grinning and
I smacked the smile off his face and
said give me a bourbon they were [__]
they played rough there man it's bondage
you know
Mr 88 said I wrote out the lyrics to Van
Halen's Panama of my book covers in
third grade I would bet I had less than
50 of the words correct
I used to do that but I was always very
anal retentive about making sure I got
the lyrics right because I would not
have written lyrics on my book unless I
words absolutely 100 sure what they were
because I didn't want nobody like
catching me out on that [__] even though
nobody that I went to school with hardly
knew any of those songs anyway so I
could have got away with it but you know
I wasn't gonna let that let that [__]
fly Zack says it stands for a private
military contractor okay
private military contractor saving
somebody where
I I forgot I forgot the content soldiers
at a private military contractor
rescuing someone okay you figured you'd
know how that [__] works well yeah well
um that that is the same premise as um
Rambo
the Fight Continues
where those mercenaries went to go
rescue rescue those people down in
Myanmar and [__] Rambo goes and [__]
that's actually the best Rambo movie
I mean that's the most like a horror
movie yeah so
I mean if you like to see people get
their heads blown off which I do yeah
Rambo doesn't all right cool
that's the one you want to watch yeah
Rambo the Fight Continues the unrated
version every time you say that it
always reminds me of Boggy Creek 2 and
The Legend Continues
well he was a wild man living out in the
[__] forests in Thailand or whatever
snakes and catching snakes sure a man's
kind of woman he was a man's kind of
woman
and then
Rambo [__] company Rambo out of
retirement he even [__] makes his own
knife to do the mission he starts
[__] working on Steel
now these guys it was pretty good then
he hooks up with a
mercenaries is that South African
mercenaries and mercenaries from all
over there's only like seven of them a
church hires them to rescue some church
people that got some Christians
Christian missionaries we got captured
Myanmar
it's a good one
Mr 88 said unless the lyrics were
printed on the insert lyrics are not
readily available like they are today
yeah that's true
um I was always like really excited when
I bought a cassette tape and I was like
please let the words be in a please and
then it would fold out but it's like
when they weren't I was like [__] now
I'm never gonna figure it out yeah Rob
was out back in the 70s but his second
album came out it's just you had to pay
real close attention to those lyrics he
wasn't high in the fact he was gay
it's ridiculous to now to look at him
and see what he was wearing that is
straight from the leather fetising which
was gay as [__]
yeah it's just well like I said people
weren't as they weren't a Savvy
background right but um
I was gonna say that I even when I was
back when I was um listening to Bauhaus
and stuff like that and they didn't use
they didn't put their lyrics in the
albums usually so I bought they actually
had like a little lyric book I think I
still have it around here somewhere
and so I didn't actually know what they
were saying most of the time and so when
I finally got the lyric book I was like
oh I was like really surprised because I
was just like man that is not what I
thought they were saying at all
because their lyrics are pretty weird
like I don't think he'd be able to like
guess them if you didn't know you know
what I mean yeah they don't make like
they're kind of um what's the word I
want to use impressionistic I guess yeah
yeah who would which band Bauhaus yeah
well also what was more abstract
abstract is that's probably a better
word their lyrics were kind of the
maximum abstract that I that I've
encountered even to to this day from a
good band was skinny puppy
skinny Puppies lyrics were just abstract
as [__] they probably would take an
article about a subject and cut the
sentences out and then cut a bunch of
sentences up throw most of them away put
them in a [__] hat and then throw
them down well that was the thing that
was the thing out of that that a lot of
kind of that type of bands were doing
yeah they were good
they were good real good and then you
had stuff like when you said abstract
lyrics you have something like the
cocktail twins yeah
man that was some sex music there man
I'm sure she was saying something
because like sometimes you can pick a
word out I'll just crying singing to the
baby or something
you can pick words out so I think she is
saying words but I think a lot of it is
just kind of like fanatic [__] that was
like Lisa Gerard yeah singing in fake
languages and [__] but it sounded good
you know from deck and dance yeah yeah
it sounds like Latin or something
but it's not a real language
Mr idiot says by the way among its many
firsts The Beatles Sergeant Pepper's was
the first album to include lyrics I
actually didn't know that so you know
there's some good trivia there also the
first to be played beginning to end on
the radio yeah I had heard that but I
didn't know that it was the first one
that had lyrics in it Beatles were good
man they were great
well I grew up listening to The Beatles
Because my dad was really into them so
it's like I I listen to The Beatles from
probably birth yeah they're good and so
I got really and when I um was learning
to play the piano that was I think the
first song that I learned how to play on
the piano like at home was obla di
Oblada yeah and I might still remember
how to play it I'm actually not sure
it's been a long time they were very
talented they were kind of like
proto-prog rock in a certain way because
they could just do anything you never
knew what they were gonna sound like
um although I gotta say when it comes to
just like hardness and grit I'd give it
to the stones I think the stones I like
them both for different reasons I like
the Beatles more because like they were
more Innovative
um and I liked and I liked that you
didn't know what to expect with them
like they experimented with a lot of
different genres but they were still
noticeably them like it was still they
still had their own style but they
experimented with a lot of different
stuff and I thought that was cool like
they pulled it off I thought the stones
were cool because they could just be
almost Gothic like with painted black
they could almost have like a Gothic
Rock sound to them and it was just way
way ahead of its time and then um then
they would the next thing you know
they'd do something that was fake
country
fake country rock like wild horses and
[__] and these yeah fake Southern
Accents
um singing about black girls and [__]
like that it's just he was he was a trip
he could get away with that [__] too he
was funny as [__] yeah dance you know he
danced [__] crazy
yeah [__] big Jagger
I haven't seen that guy in a long time
he was an ancient old man back when I
was still young
I remember in the 90s they did like a
big tour and they were talking then
about how [__] decrepit they were
like an old they were and they're like
making gents like oh my God 200 or
average the tickets were back then like
some ridiculous amount to see like all
these old codgers like running around on
stage so it's like they were old
it was like so funny that people were
like talking about and they're still
[__] alive now in 98 well most of
them were still alive 98
um Mick Jagger and the Rolling Stones
came up with a song it was really good
but I don't remember the name of it
there was a video for it and everything
he was great he was [__] dancing and
everything
um
and I was going like how does the oh
dude he I think he was in his 70s then
how's that old [__] dude then how's
that old dude [__] looking that good
and dancing like that now I would say
that [__] was taking Winstrol
wind straw and [__] anavar and [__]
like that it was the only explanation to
have that amount of energy
guy at that age
couldn't do that
to go on tour and [__] and then you look
at what was his name Keith Richards is
that his name Keith Richards yeah that
[__] looked like he was pickling
formaldehyde
they just
oh man
it looked like he was pickling you're
the [__] shrunken head that the
shrunken apples I made those I made some
of those when I was a kid
that's what he looked like I wonder if
like if there's like any young people in
there it's like do they still make
shrunken Apple Head dolls yeah that's
the way that's pretty old he was on
guitar and [__] and they were doing good
man he could play
and they're I think they're all still
alive aren't they
um well no one of them Richard's alive
yeah Keith Richards is still alive I
think kidney still alive for sure yeah
one of them is dead we would know if he
had died you would think so I mean I
don't really keep up [__] impossible
to believe that Mick Jagger outlived
David Bowie that is crazy
with all the [__] that those dudes have
done
it's just [__] depends man some
people can get away with all kind of
crap and still live forever yeah because
I think Harold was I think heroin heroin
was involved with those guys too they
look like junkies to me
yeah I mean they didn't get fat no which
is interesting I think they were just
slept like [__] family probably
wouldn't shoot up and just sleep
they wake me up when it's time to tour
right I'm just gonna sleep until then
for a few months but
uh Mr 88 says the Beatles are the best
ever they also invented the music video
when they stopped touring they still
wanted to present a performance to the
public yeah that's right uh Larry and
creature said the pretty things are a
really cool British Invasion band way
ahead of their time the stones took a
lot of their style from those guys
Jason says I went to the Stones concert
in Australia in 2014.
they were good but I bet they needed
long recovery yeah the drummer passed
away I knew one of them had died
look man as as a 54 year old dude
those dudes are doing steroids yeah
of course that's the only way
you couldn't you couldn't [__] tour
like I said the recovery period
if you did a long show like that and
[__] 70 80 year old dude it would
take him [__] weeks to recover now if
he ever did
I don't think he would recover you can't
work somebody that hard at that age
that's steroids
Rolling Stones are a blues cover band
again or the rolling bones he said the
Stone's first charting single was I want
to be your man written by Lennon
McCartney even the stones firsts were on
the backs of The Beatles
yeah I kind of feel like the stones are
more like
they're more like a bar band that made
good you know what I mean because a lot
of their songs were covers or were riffs
on and they were real simple right right
and there's nothing wrong with that like
I said a lot of punk rock is like that
too and I like that but it's just kind
of like
you know I tend to like stuff that's
like more Innovative more so that's why
I always preferred The Beatles there are
some bands though that can just do the
same thing over and over again and still
be awesome like AC yeah yeah AC DC
basically making the Same album over and
over again they just freaking they're
like why'd you do it [__] it everybody
likes it yeah and AC DC was good man
because if they did something different
everybody would cry
they never you're not good anymore in
the time that I listened to him and I
haven't heard anything real recent from
them but the time I was listening to
them all throughout all throughout the
80s in the parts of the 90s they didn't
have a Bad album
and and you could instantly recognize it
they were they were branded you know
what I mean he was yeah that's AC DC
they were good yeah I kind of feel like
that's
it's one of those things you can either
decide you're going to be one of those
bands that it's just like well we're
gonna have a sound and we're just gonna
stick to that forever
um you know which is one way to go or
you're gonna be like well we just want
to do something different every time
right which is I think that's a harder
road to hoe actually because you kind of
have to reinvent yourself every time so
it's much harder but when you can when
you're successful at it
I think like artistically you're
probably a lot better but I'm not
complaining about bands that are just
like hey we're just gonna do the same
[__] over and over because like I don't
blame you you know what I mean it's hard
coming up with new [__] you can look at
Iron Maiden and really Iron Maiden was
only good for their first like five or
six albums I like the first two Paul
giano albums
and then as they went they would try to
do the same things and it would sound
stale then they'd try something new and
it would sound [__] up and then go
back to the way they were they sound as
Stout and stale again
Metallica just destroyed Iron Maiden
they never really recovered from the
invention of Metallica there's something
about
something about Iron Maiden is that
they could not get that thrash sound
right yeah it couldn't it could not
modernize and there was something about
I'm gonna say that Iron Maiden was the
first Gothic metal band there was
something kind of Gothic about him the
first two albums were kind of like Punk
power metal Punk metal punk rock metal
and then it went but with with like
Number of the Beast and [__] peace of
mind and Power Slave there was something
Gothic about it Gothic metal
and that's really [__] what made them
great
and every time they tried to come out of
that mold
the fans wouldn't like it and they never
really could capture the energy of the
for the first three like little Gothic
metal albums I didn't like Seventh Son
of the Seventh Son or I didn't like any
of that [__] I mean it was okay but it's
just you I could tell it was getting
real stale
well I should or I could argue even
though they are a brilliant band right
but they're it's their early stuff
and it was in time although I showed
that [__] to sof loved it she listened
to every one of their albums and then
came back and go yeah you're right it's
only really like the first five albums
are good it started it gets stale and
becomes very much kind of the same thing
over and over again
like I listened to book of souls it
sounded good it sounded like something
off of peace of mind but then I was real
I'm listening to him and go you know
what this is the same old [__]
this is the same old [__] this is kind
of boring
Mr 88 said yes a reporter made a dig at
Malcolm Young from AC DC asking why they
made the Same album 13 times yeah yeah
he responded you were wrong we have made
the Same album 14 times yeah yeah yeah
there was no reason to change it well
that's what I mean it's just kind of
like what and the thing about it too is
that if you got a good thing going yeah
then you probably shouldn't change it
and I kind of feel like too sometimes
it's better to stick with what you like
if you like to do that and you like that
to be your whole shtick then don't
change it yeah I kind of feel like
sometimes you get in a thing where it's
like your band it's like oh well
everyone's doing this now so maybe we
should try to do that even though you
don't really want to do that or you're
not really good at that or that's not
really in your wheelhouse it's like just
do what you want to do yeah AC DC AC DC
was about getting drunk
if you want to get drunk to rock music
put on [__] flick of the switch or
[__] Back in Black and get hammered
to that it'll make perfect sense that
album makes perfect sense when you just
[__] loaded uh and that's that whole
band is like that it's just let's let's
get drunk it's not sophisticated at all
and that's its strength
that could play in any bar you can play
that down at the [__] biker bar here
the Oasis they'll they jam out to that
right alongside country and they would
they would because they know that one
it's just it's a very Universal kind of
rock sound
and there's not many bands that have
perfected that
well I was thinking about the whole
thing where because I know that
particularly in the 80s when all the
kind of like new wave and synth pop
stuff started happening I know that like
Khan of a lot of older bands like that
had been around in the 70s but were kind
of getting a little long in the tooth a
lot of them are like maybe we should
like do this whole synth pop thing and
then it just like didn't work out so
good I was thinking about this the other
day because I was at work and the guy
was playing
just like a random playlist and that
terrible horrible no good Awful song We
Built This City by Starship came on and
I hadn't heard that song in a really
long time but so I'm listening to it one
what the [__] are they even talking
about like what the what did those
lyrics even mean are they having a
stroke I don't know I'm like listening
to the lyrics going this makes
absolutely no sense I wish somebody
could explain what these lyrics mean why
they just pulled these straight out of
their anal cats I mean they don't make
any sense at all I don't even know what
they're talking about so but the thing
about it is that they you know Jefferson
Airplane used to be a good band yeah
yeah and then like the 80s came along
and they're like oh we're gonna do this
like cheesy scent pop thing and that
really really
um
that really wasn't ideal most people
know him from that era thankfully
thankfully now Mrs man that's awesome
it's terrible Mr 88 says that uh he
didn't really like Iron Maiden
uh but he did like the cover art
especially the killers The Killers cover
are actually Killers is iron maiden's
best album and that's a Paul Daniel
album his second one
um but they couldn't take him on tour he
had drug problem
but that's the best Iron Maiden album
it's just [__]
it's just a great
mixture of
kind of this punk rock
metal with a really hot psychedelic kind
of sound to it
I must say that
Paul diano's voice his tone is I would
say sexy really
um and Bruce Dickinson wasn't Bruce was
great but he just did not have that kind
of [__] bad boy kind of [__] heat
to his [__] voice if you listen to
that album it's just like real good
um
now that's the best thing I made now if
you ask me the best Bruce Dickinson
album though would probably be peace of
mind if not that Power Slave it kind of
was kind of like a toss-up
they're both great but I just got a real
soft spot for
peace of mind I thought that was really
good now somebody else mentioned that
Black Sabbath
probably did the uh the first Gothic
metal I I don't really think so because
the first Black Sabbath album was really
more like a really heavy
dark Mississippi delta blues mixed with
rock metal
it was good
um
and they also had a lot of psychedelic
overtones they kind of compared in some
ways to kind of like an evil version of
Jimi Hendrix
so I wouldn't say Gothic no but I know
what you mean though it does kind of
have a
to me I would say not so much Gothic
more kind of like black metal
more like black metal than Gothic metal
okay
Jason said I remember kiss was good
early days but in the 80s they turned
into a disco sound kiss was the kiss was
a
kiss was run by Gene Simmons and Gene
Simmons was like why should I why should
I sell you
an album with a bunch of hits on it when
I can sell you 10 albums each with one
hit it was like that
um and then a bunch of other [__] I
found out yeah
why don't I sell you a belt buckle why
don't I sell you [__] some lunch
boxes why don't I sell you you know it
was more about merchandise not gonna lie
my brother had that kiss lunchbox not
gonna lie
kiss hat for the 70s Kiss had awesome
looking merchandise it looked cool
their album covers were [__] badass
that Destroyer album cover when I was in
third grade we saw that [__] we're like
what the [__] look how awesome that [__]
is man [__] Gene Simmons with his
tongue and I'm like is his tongue really
that long and little kids would be like
yeah it is it's that long his tongue is
like a two feet long and it's forked you
know and it rolls out like a wrap it
rolls it out of my house and you can
walk on it yeah
part lizard you know
[Laughter]
he's one of the reptilians yeah
somebody's talking about hawkwind yeah
yeah Linda kilmister from Motorhead was
in that van yeah yeah they had a damn
hippie chick running around naked and
[__] they had a couple good songs that I
remember listening to when I was young
but I haven't heard any other stuff in a
long time it was when I think about it
it was all right I really liked uh
I like Motorhead a lot that first time
everybody likes motor yeah the first
album on parole has a bunch of [__]
good out good songs on it Iron Horse
which is like an ultimate British biker
song
um
no I was [__] Lemmy was he was he was
a god [__] was a god
um and everybody liked him he's a nice
guy hang out at The Viper Room a lot
just get drunk and talking about tanks
he loved [__] World War II uh
Weaponry tanks aircraft he knew
everything
Ally Allied aircraft and axis aircraft
he knew and tanks mostly tanks I think
he liked
Larry says yeah Stacia was the naked
hippie chick on stage dancing with
hawkwind yeah and then mango said to be
honest who has not been in Hall Queens
let me start it off as their Roadie I
think and then ended up being in that
band
then I think he went to another band for
a while and then he became
and then he did his own with uh
Motorhead
there's a lot of good interviews with
Lemmy and
filthy animal Taylor and
who's the other guy
fast Eddie Clark
and they are just constantly taking the
piss out of [__] Lemmy about stealing
his girlfriends and everything [__]
Phil Taylor [__] stole his girlfriend
and it's funny to see dudes that are so
tight that they could just [__] with
each other about stealing yeah and
that's the last other girl's girlfriend
I thought he said man you know that's
your bro when you put up with that [__]
well yeah that's the thing it's like
because you know you've known them so
long and it's like see you know they're
not doing it like to be mean or anything
like that that's why you can really only
[__] with people that you yeah are
really really nice I detected nothing
but just love yeah between those those
well that's what's so funny about it
it's like they sound like they're
constantly like sniping but you can tell
that it's very good nature yeah they
were they were those those dudes it's
not me they were all Brothers really
right
well like I said that's kind of the
thing where really only you can talk to
other people like that with yeah you
know well it's like a military unit
that's the way military guys are if
they've been in service together
especially they go through basic
training together just that constant
[__]
well I mean that's kind of like what
like if you like for example if you have
siblings that are really good it's like
me and my sister or my brothers and
stuff like that I mean we can say like
[__] up [__] to each other all the
time and we just like it's fine you know
what I mean yeah just because you know
because it's true one is true too you
can't really retaliate and yeah it's
funny anyway [__] yeah it's funny anyway
yeah that's what I mean and you don't
mean it like I said you don't mean it
like a mean spirited away everybody's
[__] up everybody's got problems you
know what I mean it's fine
you guys said I was gonna dress up as
Lemmy last Halloween with prosthetics
and all that but had to work oh well
that would be a good costume actually
that would be a good costume I don't
think I ever saw anybody you should
dress up as Lemmy in his cut-off shorts
have you ever seen that [__] photo
yeah then you got cut off shorts they
were cutting a v like they're like like
chick shorts with his ass taken out of
the pack well I kind of feel like he
didn't think there was anything strange
about it well everything he was his boss
everybody that was the 70s right uh 80s
when he had that [__] well okay seven
years but I kind of well in the 70s and
80s like dudes were like super short
shorts and like nobody yeah
10 years out of date oh okay and playing
video games and those things that they'd
come up with because like the shorts
dude and he's like yeah yeah it's hot
out here
it's like are they squishing here
[Laughter]
um all right so it's nine o'clock oh
it's time to go so I well yeah and don't
rush me because I still gotta get
dressed and I don't and I don't know
what I'm gonna wear take your time but
um yeah I'd probably I was gonna get
another drink but I guess not no we'll
drink when we get there all right
um
Mr 88 said if you dress this Lemmy you
could have a child pair with you as
Lemmy's mole
I mean yeah yeah I kind of feel like
that oh yeah okay all right so we will
be back on
Sunday and we will finally finally be
talking about Black Hawk Down because I
guess we're gonna watch it tomorrow
night and then we'll talk about it on
Sunday because Louie sent it to us and
we have been looking forward to watching
it we just hadn't had time yet so yeah
that's what we're gonna do uh so
hopefully you guys had a good time
hanging out with us tonight and we'll
see you guys again on Sunday good night